one of my favorite videos I've watched
it maybe ten times is when you were
onstage with Bowie doing all the young
dudes you know it was like guys from
Mott the Hoople were up there with them
and you guys
yeah and Queen was up there Brian May
and you guys got up this thing back up
from Bowie and I dragged him up it
wasn't gonna do it I said you're gonna
regret this for the rest of your life if
you don't
was it a chilling moment for you to do
that I mean with all your success and
everything else to take one of your
heroes and be up on stage with them and
all the young dudes by the way is that
his best song maybe it's my favorite
song of all time so for me it was a
no-brainer but to look across that stage
is me Phil and Brian down one Mike
looking at Queen - Fred but with Ronson
Bowie and Hunter doing it it was like
let's finish you don't want to lose
total ease pinching yourself it's an
amazing if anyone's never seen that
video you gotta watch it it's really
good I really I get the chills when I
watch it why is all the young dudes the
best song ever written
don't know caught me at the right moment
it's everything about it it's the words
it's the lyrics it's when a that the
production that what he stands for
for me it's just the song of my
generation is the king of him when was
the first time you met the guy Bowie
yeah first time I met him was at Bono's
house look at you name dropper right now
do you guys all hang out if I was why
does Joe get to hang out of bars how to
aggravate the rest of you guys that the
singer gets to hang out of one of his
farewell sound and vision tour
supposedly in 1990 and bonnell through a
barbecue barbecue and he invited me
niece is a come with me I want to
introduce you to somebody and he walks
me up into his room where the snooker
table is and Bowie sat on the snooker
table and Bono just says warning tell
him what you gave him
what you gave Bowie oh well yeah back
the day after we were talking and we
were talking about all the young dudes
and his aborted version from the Aladdin
Sane sessions and he says I've not only
four years and I said I've got it and he
went really so the next night which is
when the gig was I saw him backstage
before he went on and I gave him a
okay put it knees top okay why don't
stage no kidding you mean you gave him a
cassette of the song he didn't have they
each recorded with his spiders so let me
get this straight because this is a good
story you go over to Bono's house Bono
knows what a big fan you are a Bowie
this guy is pretty nice Bono I mean any
he sets up a room where Bowie will sit
and he's gonna escort you in and
surprise you yeah
Bowie's in on this yeah yeah they say
hey Jose really you know this guy is
really into you and they set it up it's
like a date anyone I thought it's been
punked until he got even better because
once you know that the night went on
edge wasn't there cuz it was his
birthday so his wife had took him for
dinner and Bowie said let's go and
surprise him so we jump in this Mini
Cooper that Bono's you know one of his
assistants got and there's me Bono the
guy driving and Bowie in this little
mini we drive all the way to dun
Laoghaire into a restaurant we run into
the restaurant we sing happy birthday to
the edge and everybody's giggling and
laughs he would get back in the car and
drive back Bowie's told instigating all
this like a kid Wow we get back in Coco
his assistant went mental
because she thought we'd kidnapped him
all that's fantast
that's a good night